back to the olympics now we're
introducing you to one of the stars
of team usa water polo goalkeeper ashley
johnson
she's already a gold medal winner from
rio and the trailblazing athlete is a
champion
of overcoming racial barriers and
water-related sports
a report found nearly 64 percent of
african-american children have no
or a low swimming ability putting them
at a higher risk of drowning
that's compared to 40 percent of white
children experts say
one reason is america's history of
banning black people from public pools
and beaches
jamie yukis met with ashley and joins us
again
from tokyo jamie i can't wait to see the
story i read it but it
it's better to see you and out there in
the water with ashley
i'm still tired jerica as a matter of
fact for my time in the pool with ashley
ashley johnson says she's sometimes
overwhelmed by her role as the only
african-american woman to make the u.s
olympic water polo team
but she's also inspired by all the
stories she's heard
of young black children getting involved
in aquatic sports
that inspiration truly goes both ways
and it's what keeps her motivated both
in and out of the pool
nice to meet you nice to meet you i've
never met someone in the pool before
really it might be the best way to meet
an olympic water polo star
neck deep in her natural habitat are you
still swimming right now
yeah i'm i'm treading this is my rest it
is
yeah you're not trying to rest right
here no oh man
[Laughter]
but to really understand the athleticism
of ashley johnson
you've got to tread a mile in her swim
cap in 2016
johnson helped lead the u.s women's
water polo team to a gold medal in rio
for most athletes an olympic gold medal
would be their biggest accomplishment
but not johnson she also made history as
the first african american woman
on the u.s olympic water polo team why
do you think
many african americans don't participate
in water polo the biggest barrier to
entry
is the narrative that black people don't
swim that
needs to go away i heard so many times
growing up that
i didn't belong here and not always in
that direct way but
indirectly like oh what are you doing
here like how did you get here
this is where it began 23 years ago when
i bought a house with a pool
she got there by starting out here with
her four siblings in the backyard pool
at her mom's house in miami but of
course the pool became
a big thing to me because i had
nightmares and of them all drowning
so i thought i had to get them all to
swim i had to
get them to learn to swim when i go home
and i get in the pool
i'm like this pool is so small and it
seemed so
big when we were young big but not big
enough
by high school ashley was an all-county
honored swimmer
even though i hate swimming
so everyone hates swimming low-key but
no one says it
i really love being a part of a team
working with group dynamics
and swimming didn't give me any of that
how were you able to convince
people in your life that you didn't want
to swim but you wanted to play water
polo i had a deal with my swim coach in
high school my sophomore year that if i
won
the 50 free in the state championship
then i would never have to swim again
he was like okay thinking i wouldn't do
it first of all the coach should know
better
you just don't give ashley a goal like
that i mean anything you tell her that
like she can't do
essentially she's gonna do just throw
the ball
out here the fact that now her coach's
team usa's adam kirkorian
tells you how the deal back in high
school worked out she's one of the best
to ever play the game in her position
when she's dialed in i mean it's so
intense
if you look deep into her eyes you can
see the focus and the drive to
to be the best no one wants to get balls
tossed at them at
40 miles per hour but the balls come at
you at 40 miles an hour
yeah that's great just remember i need
my face for work
that intensity is intimidating when
you're face to face with her across the
surface of a pool
ready maybe okay
[Laughter]
but out of the pool that focus turns to
something else
entirely i see my biggest role as being
a mirror
for young girls and young boys to see
themselves in like
know that there's someone up here who's
different representation is everything
if you can't see yourself at the highest
level in your sport
achieving whatever goal you want to
achieve how can you
visualize yourself getting there and now
people can envision
an african-american olympic gold medal
winner and water polo
yes exactly
ashley and her teammates are now a few
steps closer to adding to that metal
collection
over the weekend they defeated the
japanese by a score of 25 to 4
and then went on to best the chinese
team to 7.
they still must face the hungarians and
the russians before hopefully
advancing to the quarterfinals next
tuesday anthony jamie yukas in tokyo and
one thing we learned already
this is a lot harder than it looks jamie
oh my goodness the pool's like 12 feet
deep i mean
and you she has to pick her whole body
up out of the water to be able to block
those
those scoring you know the goals so it's
just it's incredible what she does
yeah i know gail kept saying here you
mean she can't actually touch i didn't
realize
until your your story jamie that when
they're standing in the goal swimming
that they're swimming and having to
paddle the whole time
that is exhausting so how were you able
to stay up
because you stayed up a pretty you
stayed up a pretty good while
well i grew up in the land of ten
thousand lakes right so we started
swimming very very early on so i learned
how to tread water when i was probably
about three or four years old so
um i've been swimming a long time but
that was probably the hardest thing i've
ever done
and i quickly got out of the pool when
they said cut
we're ready for the interview i was out
all right jimmy yukis again in tokyo
thanks jamie